i used to awake in the morning
before the sun had time to shine and i
only had one thought on my mind
i was thinking how can i cop a [ __ ]
dime
no cocaine got nailed in my brain
it caused my mind to go insane so i used
to jump to my feet
and i was off to the street i was
looking for
a [ __ ] i thought i could beat
and damn i looked down
and i didn't even have no shoes on my
feet you see in more ways than one
my pipe became my gun and it was pointed
straight in my face
and it led me to this most lonely place
you see it was a called addiction square
but i said
[ __ ] it because all my homies lived
there
i had peter pipe lizzie lighter cookie
cocaine
phillip flame dulo linda and it was
lying as brenda
and it was always recycled michael you
see we was part of a cocaine chain gang
and none of us even knew each other's
real given name
my name is stephanie
so hold on cause a real funny story just
entered my brain you see me and my homie
we chilling one night and two drunk
[ __ ]
they started a fight now peter piper
broke his ring like a cookie cocaine in
a brenda's hand
lying excellent that she ran to the
phone she was gonna tell snitch mitch
what the [ __ ] was going on recycle
michael was standing there holding a
beer can
and lo and behold we all got gaffled by
that white man
now it was never part of my plan do you
understand
because on its mystic road it's full of
twists
and turns and with no direction your
destination will be
unknown you see on mr grove your guide
is self-defense to only trust
take care of yourself now that's if you
have any sense
and this mystic road is hidden away
and only the hopeless can find the way
but only the truly lost will stay and on
mystic road
guide in your scenery will be nothing
but
fire and broken glass
so those of you with any pride stay your
ass
inside and hide save yourself from the
streets
and when they happen to ask you
post the toast you tell them it came
from girly girl
tell them coast to coast
i'm mr girly girl
they call me girly girl where are you
from originally where'd you grow up
i grew up here in los angeles california
from the projects to windsor hills
to 98th and figaro i went to school in
the valley
and when they first started busting
kids to the valley and i think that's
that's one of the greatest things that
ever happened to me
was being able to pretty much
live two lives i came home to the ghetto
and then i went to school with
kids that were different than myself of
all ethnicities
and and i got to make friends and learn
things
about people and still
i lived and had to live in the ghetto
i mean you that's what we call it they
get
how was your childhood my childhood
my childhood was one of um
battling for my identity pretty much
you see because all my brothers and
sisters they have the same
father and i'm a product of
um infidelity of
romance that didn't work my mother
was sleeping with a married man she
named me
after one of his children i have a
i have another sister with the exact
same name
and so fighting with my identity
um by her giving me his last name
and having two families that way and
my mother is an alcoholic okay
um it's pretty much
always feeling left out always feeling
like
i'm the oddball y'all daddy ain't y'all
daddy and
ain't mine and them
by me being the baby and my mom babying
me because
she felt some type of guilt about
what she had done but i was already here
that she you know she took
i don't know if you want to say uh she
she
never really tried to separate us but
everybody could tell
that she would give me a little bit more
leniency and and
you know she tried to comfort me more
because that i was the eyeball
i was the one that was
out of wedlock um by a married man
i was the one that had the different
last name
i was the one
that but i was the baby
when you were when you were a kid did
you have dreams of doing something with
your life other than this
yes i was actually
you never would think i actually was
in high school really popular um
most likely to succeed i was the
cheerleader
for cedar high school um
drama club all that i had
i i focused myself in anything that i
could
for people to be proud of me
other than keep pushing me back
keep because i really didn't belong
it felt like i didn't belong in the
family that i was in
because how could i have i felt your
daddy yay
my daddy ain't your daddy where your
daddy yeah your daddy your
your daddy marry you and then and then
the married man can't take care of his
child
so i i strived
for things like a poetry
once i have words it was the way that i
could express
myself but still
never being able to fit in because it
seemed like
everybody always thought it was a weirdo
thing
you know when when younger kids it seems
like i've always had this sense of
i could i could be alone and i couldn't
express myself because i was so shy
i didn't want anybody to just say
anything bad to me anymore
i didn't want to hear anymore
oh shut up you ain't even got no damn
and so i would just
put myself like plant myself into myself
and then when i heard poetry and i would
learn how to you know read books it was
just a way that
i was able to fight against people
with my with my words or
because it seems like i was always like
kind of odd
like so at some age
at some point you got exposed to this
lifestyle
yeah um i went to
las vegas in 1991
and i was 20 almost 21 years
no yeah i was like
before my 21st birthday well long story
short i went there to go to unlv
imagine that and um i
got enrolled and still once again
i'm really shy i'm really you know back
then i'm really kind of cute
uh what have you so i started dating all
kinds of
guys i cannot say their names
but on the basketball level they became
to be
something um back then and
um i i started
less studying because i was the youngest
one
i graduated when i was 16. less studying
and more hanging okay because i wanted
to be part
of something and be popular with people
that wasn't gonna call me names
and i could truly be wow i'm
everything so i started hanging out with
this older crowd
and sex
okay because if you want to fit in
you got to do what everybody else does
you get it
you have to do hey if they're doing it
and you want to be part of
it and you want to make this whole
life and thing for yourself you got to
go with it
so i'm pretty much was like that go with
it girl
if they were doing it and it made me
popular
and it made me part of something i damn
well was doing it
so i started snorting cocaine i started
just sleeping around you know um
but it was always what i could do
the most i could do for them to make
them like me
if you wanted to use my car here you
could have it
if you had money needed money and i
really didn't have it
it didn't matter just as long as i felt
like you liked me
and so you start so you started working
in vegas
yeah um did you drop out of school
i dropped out of course i was snorting
cocaine
i was loaning people money that i didn't
even have to snort my own cocaine
trying to fit in and then eventually
you know the other girls was telling me
about how
uh this person's name this guy
that guy he'll give you money and and
whoo
but when i got to that guy there were
things that i had to do for that money
and with wanting to snort all those
lines
then i did what it was
i had to do for that line
and it was like a different part it was
way different
in vegas than it is down here
in south central east side baby east
side
you see so i come from vegas i'm snoring
lines
with big wigs valleys i'm i'm snoring
lines with presidents of entertainment
i'm storing lines with with
uh people uh i'll just say
italians um
they're buying me cards and
this and this and this and that it was
way different
it wasn't like standing out in the
freezing cold
with a pair of little shorts not
even to get enough to pay put gas in
your car none of the girls even had
cars you see so i i i leave one point
of my life because i got a stalker i'm
stuck
i'll probably go so fast cause i get
nervous in vegas
while i was doing my thing and
getting drunk and getting high with all
these big wigs
i got a stalker and this stalker
they could never catch him in the act he
was a boyfriend of mine he would take me
out to the desert he
beat beat me until i was black and blue
always on my legs
uh when i would call the police on him
his mother would always give him an
alibi the police
officer one police officer finally told
me
you know what you need to just
go somewhere for a minute and let this
thing die down you feel me well i was
already dating
a guy that was a bus driver a charter
bus
driver so i figured
let me go with the charter bus driver
and
go to california until the stalker thing
died down
well in being a bus driver he was never
home
and now i'm on 116th and broadway
and i am coming from 106th broadway i
mean you know i
i've been living since i was 21
to i'm 27 28 in vegas i've been doing
big things
i've been having money i've been you
know i've been around people outside of
my race
i ain't been living in a neighborhood
where there's only black people
i ain't been living in no gangbanger
neighborhood and
none of that i didn't have the kind of
girlfriends that
we can go and have lunch and still snort
cocaine and not steal from each other
but i come to 106
and i still have this habit
and he doesn't know but
you people other drug addicts can peep
out other
you know drug addicts it's just like
there's a look
like like a magnet you
so i connected and i saw somebody and
and he saw me and
i knew and he knew that
i was a drug user so he approached me
and asked me to i wanted to do some
drugs and i said
yes hell yeah because my dude was always
gone
and so then i started using drugs and
down the street from my new home
and in order for these people in order
for this guy not to tell on me
i started doing things that he wanted me
to do and then
since i was so different like you said
he's like you can get paid that you you
will get paid
and he was like a big uh like the guy
that everybody was scared of
dope dealer in the neighborhood
everybody was scared of him
he used to go around with a bat he'll
beat people up
if you didn't do what he said and i was
under his thumb because i didn't want my
boyfriend
to find out that i was using drugs
and within using drugs
i started meeting all the other
you know local girls and prostitutes
that was using drugs
i speak different um i always had like
designer clothes i'm sorry i did i had
designer clothes i'm driving
cars i don't even know how to smoke
crack
because he gave me crack i used to snort
but he gave me crack
i really don't even i don't even know
what it's supposed to look like
i'm just doing this because i was caught
i was caught
in a rock and a hard place and
they taught me how to you know when when
i had
depleted all the money that my
my man would give me and i couldn't
produce any of the things
to account for the money that he had
given me
the light bill the uh where's the
groceries
um you haven't bought nothing new
where's all the money
then i started like they like they
showed me
walk down broadway yeah [ __ ]
you go get it and when they pull over
and ask you are you dating yeah yeah
only go to this motel only do this
and so i learned how to i guess
prostitute hoe whatever you want to call
it out here
but it damn well wasn't the same as
vegas because i was a whole a long time
ago
once i think about it once i think about
it but for the price
it didn't seem like it so so you've been
working in l.a ever since
yeah l.a long beach uh
downtown i have a different name
everywhere
i do you got tents kemp's or no
um yeah i've been kidnapped by pimps
it was always a kidnap situation
yeah i've been thrown out of a car on
the freeway
yeah i've been kidnapped i've been
sliced
paralyzed yeah i've had the worst of it
but always only time i've ever had a
pimp
was by hostage
and being afraid to to run
i've been sold by another um
prostitute by another hoe sold me on the
downlow
i didn't know
do you have kids yes i have two
daughters
did you raise them no um
my first daughter
uh i stayed with her until she was two
and my second daughter
i really don't know who her father
is but my dude
took the responsibility and he loved me
enough to just say she's
minds once he found out that i was
using i have no idea to this day
and i'd hate to break her heart like
this
but i gotta free minds i have no
i kind of have a clue but
i can't tell her who he is 100
and are you still working today i'm an
opportunist
when things get hard let me tell you
i try try it on the best road
but sometimes things don't go as planned
it's not at the level that i was doing
it
but don't get me wrong
if the bill is due and the opportunity
presents itself
then i have no choice it's going down
you ever get depressed doing this a lot
a lot a lot
it's hard right it's it's so hard
because you don't want to sometimes
most of the time but there is no
there's no avenue there's no there's no
phone calls you can make
there's no no um status of
credit that you have to withdraw funds
that
that you're not gonna get so you use
what you got
you're living day by day day by day
pretty much do you feel like you're
addicted to this life
that's good i um
i'm not addicted to this to the life you
know what
i'm addicted to
having to have what it is that i need
and by any means and i know
my qualifications can get it you feel me
i'm not addicted to every day that it
gives
like an everyday thing that it'll give
me such an excitement
but i i am addicted to the to the point
that
knowing that i can i can go get it this
way
that turns me on that if i have to
i can bust it wide and go get it
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that work the
street like this
is that they they have no goals or are
they
that they are not the type of material
that would make
a good wife a good mother
a good housekeeper a good person
that they that they are nothing that
they're trash and i think people are
very misunderstood
that it takes a hell of
but the heart of a gunslinger to do what
it is that they do
and and it does not take away from the
fact
if they can cook if they can clean or if
they will be loyal to you
that's what i think
how do you think that living this
lifestyle for the years you have has
changed you
it's changed me in the sense that now it
was
hard to to feel real true sexual emotion
until i had to back off of it a little
bit
and it changes you that
when somebody like making love or
having sex with somebody and it's not
about business you feel it feels
different it feels so different
it's like you come to a point where you
can't
you have to separate the two and it's
really
a mental thing and it changed me because
i have to learn how to how to feel that
way again
what you're saying is it's difficult to
it's difficult to feel love
if you're doing this every night yeah
it's really difficult that's that's
always been my suspicion is it's
difficult to separate the two it is so
difficult
you can't just like go make love to 10
guys every night and then
fall in love with somebody else the next
day you you can't it's
it's it's this is something you know
this ain't no garlic thing but it's just
something that has to grow and it's
something that we have
that you have to overcome and
that's how it's it's changing because
separating one touch from the other one
trying to feel
[Music]
you can't do you think doing this kind
of work
night after night kind of breaks a
girl's self-worth
breaks her psyche yeah i i i i really do
it weakens you as
your your i guess your soul gets beaten
down
yeah and then it's hard to to even
be able to accept anything better right
i've seen that a lot yeah
yeah yeah you're right because of the
treatment
that that
a lot of men most men out there have
that you're only here for one reason you
can't be used and abused every night and
then all of a sudden
right accept a good a better life right
how can you
how can you be treated like
a tool and then in the second breath
have someone look at you and say they
really love you
how could you how could you truly
believe that what would give you that
belief when it's the same species
a man do you understand me it takes
it takes the kind of man that is going
to stick around
and stick with you through this
knowing that this is what you have done
having you to have faith in yourself
with the faith that they gonna give
you and help you grow out of it to help
you grow
out of it yeah because nothing you can't
do it by yourself
you're not going to yeah finding
somebody who's got that it's going to
take the same thing that made you feel
bad to make you feel good yeah and
somebody has somebody's gonna have the
patience to ride that out with you is
gonna be
hard to find right a man yeah you're
gonna need the same one to put you
down to build you up you're going to
need a man
you're going to need a man that makes
you feel worthy
beautifully said i don't think many
people understand that
has this affected the way you view men
do you respect men less because of this
kind of work
um no um okay
i don't respect all men less i just
now know what to look for
in signs of the predator
and signs of the king
i can i can differentiate use your
intuition
what oh you i'm now
all that you talking you can say that
while you're walking
but you okay he's a king
it helped me now i can tell the
difference when before
i couldn't
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your years of doing this
i've learned that i am worthy
and just because i have something
i don't have to use it as a tool maybe
my tits my ass and my [ __ ]
that i can come higher with my brain
i've learned that a real person you do
not have to take shame for
anything that you do when you did it for
a means to an
end and i've learned to not be ashamed
of anything that i've done
and that my today's and my yesterdays
they can be my business but i can share
with the world
don't be ashamed of it learn
something from it and whenever you have
to do it you can call it what you want
to
but i'm still you got to survive
and i've learned how to survive and try
to mend myself
through it and all men
they're not bad man you just have to
learn
what it is that you want to accept and
how you want to do it
you can call it what you want to i call
myself i'm an opportunist
because i'm going to tell you before i
go out in the dark
before i can't feed my kids before i
can't
um buy tissue
i'll make the decision and if i have to
do it again i will
with no shame
so do do what you want to do don't have
no shame about it
but you don't have to do what somebody
tells you to do
you don't to do it for no reason have a
very good
reason for decisions that you make make
every move count
that's what i've learned all right girly
girl
very interesting
you